Margaret in World building what do you
mean by if you make it personal you will
make it Universal
I think it's so important to think about
how
you can make a story extremely personal
and
authentic to your voice for people to
understand it in a greater context
I made the mistake when I first started
out as a writer thinking that I would
write something that everyone would love
and you know looking at all the my
favorite movies and books and everything
and trying to find a story that is
pleasing to everyone and
I I over the years I learned that it's
really when you dive deep into yourself
and trying to find the stories that
really make
you who you are in your own life
um and drawing upon those experiences
life experiences to make it
feel genuine and personal in any story
that you work on later in life and so
when I work on anything I draw on that
personal experience because
anyone you know a visitor reader a
spectator can feel
that it's not authentic or Genuine if
it's something that's fabricated and the
more that you make it personal
I find that you know this is the whole
phrase of write what you know I didn't
understand that until later on in life
but now I understand that that's what it
means that you have to make it personal
in order for people to understand and
that it goes back to
uh you know what makes us human the
universal human truths that we all share
we all love hate we understand revenge
and envy and jealousy and all of these
things but we all experience it in
different worlds and contexts with
different people in our lives and you
know different situations but when you
make it personal and you draw on
something that is extremely felt
um in your own way and you're able to
express that and manifest that into a
story that is extremely personal to you
then I believe it is universal to anyone
who experiences it
Margaret what's the three second rule
that you refer to in your new book
so the three second rule is if you're
creating a world or
um an immersive experience
if your audience member doesn't
understand the world they're in in three
seconds or less
then you have not successfully
um suspended their disbelief and this
idea came uh you know the first time I
heard it was a story about George Lucas
when he was creating his um the Star
Wars universe is that when an audience
member looks at a Star Wars world and if
it doesn't feel and he was creating it
you know if it doesn't feel like
something that belonged in the world he
was creating then it does not belong
um so it was a really interesting way to
look at the world that you're creating
to make sure that it's consistent
throughout
um your whole experience and if you're
creating something that is truly
immersive then it should feel immersive
from every to every single detail from
beginning to end and it should be it
should all speak uh you know in the same
you know it should feel like it belongs
in the same world World it should feel
like it isn't jarring or that it's out
of context or it breaks the pattern of
your world it's a way for the audience
to connect the dots and continue that
journey and that believability that they
are living in this or stepping into this
immersive world so it's a really great
way for you to look at the world that
you're creating whether it's in a video
game or a or an experience of physical
experience if you have someone walk in
and look at a place and in three seconds
if they don't tell you
exactly what you're trying to build then
you need to get back to work you need to
figure out a way that it can be because
our minds work so fast and we easily
break the world all the time
um as visitors and participants to an
experience that you want to ensure that
you never give your audience member or
visit an opportunity to break out of
your world and so
try the three second rule to create an
experience and a story that is truly
immersive so three seconds it's almost
like a couple blinks of an eye yeah yeah
that's how quickly you absorb the
environment that you're in I mean this
is a survival skill right that we as
human beings like we know that we're in
a safe place in a dangerous place it's a
fight and flight response
um fight or flight and so for us to
quickly make sense of our environment
and our surroundings is something that
we as humans evolved to do so you know
in three seconds or less if you know
where you are and you can quickly make
sense of things then you feel safe
and when you have that safety then
you're willing to play then you're
willing to engage so you have to create
that safety net first and that's
something that is extremely important in
World building because if we really want
to take it back what is it Maslow's
hierarchy yeah the Maslow's hierarchy of
needs exactly so so security safety I'm
not sure where they fall on that scale
oh yeah that's the most basic thing
right that you feel um safe that your
life isn't threatened and then from
there you're able to enjoy the luxuries
and the pleasures of life so once you
create that safety net of knowing that
you know you're and that's why like when
you we create any type of immersive
experiences we always start with
um the uh the world the uh the rules or
the Rules of Engagement so you know you
say things like
um you know please ensure that you uh
you know whatever it is keep to the path
you know don't touch this or whatever so
that you have that sense of safety
before you enter the world and that's
one thing right to create those
parameters those safety guard rails if
you will the pool rules the swimming
pool rules and once you enter that
experience how do you create that next
step of once you've established that
safety that you can enter a place and
feel safe in those three seconds as well
you know
um and from there you know unless you
have you're building a horror house
which you don't want to feel safe right
you want to be terrified and scared and
running for your life but in any other
situation where you want people to play
and engage you have to ensure that they
feel safe first and foremost to interact
with others to play to engage to
discover to explore can they open
drawers
um but having that rule of the the three
second rule of looking around and
quickly figuring out okay this is a this
is a place that I can quickly
um you know in my mind know that I'm
gonna in this world I'm immersed in it
I'm safe to do the things that I'm
supposed to do is a really great way for
you to win your audience uh immediately
when they start the experience
in your book immersive storytelling I
think it was further in page 186 or so
you say as humans we need to have idle
time and occasionally be bored and
unproductive yes and I love hearing that
because I think a lot of times as
creative people we feel like I'm not
inspired today yeah there must be
something wrong like why why can't I do
something creative yeah
I believe in being bored and
unproductive wholeheartedly I think that
you know when we really think back to
um you know at least for me in my time
being a kid and not and feeling that
boredom and not having anything to do
um that's really when I you know pulled
out the blank sheet of paper when I took
my the felt and my scissors and glue and
started creating things and making
things
um and really trying to going learning
about that creative process and whether
it was good or bad it didn't matter I
just wanted to create and as you get
older you start you know editing
yourself and like judging yourself
before you even create the thing and
then you quit or you stop because it's
not great or you know you think that
someone else does it better or you know
all these things but I think that being
bored and unproductive
um is a great way to quiet your mind and
to reset and to shut out all the other
voices that's telling you what you
should be doing what you should be
creating and when you're bored and
unproductive
you'll be surprised to hear you know
your inner voice your inner artist about
uh and your inner creative about what's
meaningful to you you know when you stop
hearing other people's opinions and
um perspective on what you should be
doing in your in your life or what
project you should be working on next
and all this and I think that during the
pandemic and when we were isolating and
in our homes that was something that I
experienced in you know very
um uh in an
extreme form like all of us that we are
locked into our houses we couldn't do
anything about it we were bored our mind
out of our minds and we wanted to do
something again and for me personally it
felt like I needed to had have that
reset button to realize what is
important to me what's still important
to me what's no longer important to me
right and being
board and an unproductive helps you to
really have that open space in your mind
to accept what comes in
and
you'll be surprised you know you'll be
surprised by what does enter your mind
and your imagination when you're not
constantly inundated with noise and
chatter and uh distractions and so uh I
recommend everyone be bored and
unproductive at least one day out of the
week
I think that's a problem for some people
because over scheduling is its own form
of addiction yeah and so I think they
feel like I'm not being good if I don't
have like all these things that I have
lined up yeah like there's something
wrong with me oh yeah and it's a
constant struggle for me too you know
because especially uh you know living in
La is also I remember when I first moved
to LA people are like you know rushing
from one thing to the next and I
remember
thinking oh I don't have that much to do
you know I actually have time to sit
around here for two hours and have lunch
but people were rushing from one thing
to the next and it affected me you know
over the years I'm like oh I have to be
busy too I have to be productive I have
to work on five to six projects at a
time like everyone else because that way
um that's how I would want the world to
perceive me as a very productive
creative or you know writer or artist
and after a while I realized well who am
I doing this for and you know if if it
is to please others then that is
definitely not my priority
um because life is short and we need to
do the the things that we ultimately are
meant to do in this world and in this
lifetime so being bored and unproductive
once in a while I'm not saying all the
time right because we all need to you
know do our things to earn money and you
know whatever it is as we do but it's
it's a really great reminder at least to
know that you don't always have to be
productive as
a human being as an individual that you
need time to rest you need time to fill
your well because that's something that
you know as a creative I
just need to walk around you know I need
to take a hike I need to do my yoga I
need to maybe walk around in a museum
without any goals at all and wander and
get lost and not have a destination and
maybe let someone else plan something
for me for a while you know and just let
go of all of those expectations
just for a while you know to have your
mind
refresh itself and to really
um you know think about what's um you
know what the most important things to
you will surprisingly come to mind
um because you know oftentimes I think
we clutter our minds and our lives and
some people do that in you know in
manifests in actual things like when
they when people start cluttering their
houses and things like that right
um it's the same thing with our mind and
the more you let in
the more you perhaps start to lose what
makes you you and there's never going to
be another you in this lifetime or in
this you know in in the history of
humankind so uh why not why not just you
know let yourself
um
be unproductive not do anything so that
you can listen to your inner voice to
tell you what it is that you need to
do or not do I think it's a really great
way to gain perspective on your life and
it's something that you need to
occasionally do in your life